yesterday on sirius xm nfl radio talking
about defensive end yannick and gaque
still hasn't signed his franchise tag 17
million plus for 2020 a report emerged
on wednesday that a trade was imminent
that hasn't happened we talked yesterday
at length about how difficult it is to
trade a guy after the deadline for
signing him to a multi-year deal it just
is difficult to do we saw the seahawks
get jadavian county last year from the
texans and the texans ended up paying
almost half of jadavian clowney's
franchise tender to make it happen so as
we play a little what's more likely with
jadavian clowney not relevant he's still
available we're talking about yannick
and goku see how i covered up my mistake
there i just kept talking yannick and
gawkway is it more likely that he ends
up with a playoff contender or
begrudgingly plays for the jaguars and
by begrudgingly for more than 17 million
dollars this year shireen what do you
think is more likely
well first of all i i love that dave
caldwell takes a page out of bill
parcells playbook and calls him the
player he never mentioned his name of
course maybe he can't uh pronounce
yannick and gagwe and and so he chose to
just call him the player but i think the
player is going to end up playing for
the jaguars
for a million dollars per week he's not
going to turn that down he's going to
end up showing up the week of the season
opener and signing that franchise tag
you guys you and chris sims had had a
great
made some great points yesterday about
how difficult it is to trade a guy on a
franchise tag who a has not signed the
tag but b you can't negotiate that
long-term deal with if they're going to
get something for him it's not going to
be very much i think they're going to
end up holding on to him for a year and
he'll be in probably a free agent march
and this notion that people are scoffing
at the jaguars reluctance to trade
yannick and gawkway for whatever they
can get because they ultimately traded
jaylen ramsey last year remember they
got two first round picks and a fourth
round pick for jalen ramsey they weren't
going to trade him unless and until they
got what they wanted and they're not
going to trade yannick and gawkway
unless and until they get what they want
the problem is
because you can't sign yannick and
gawkway to a long-term deal if you trade
for him it's going to be hard to give
the jaguars what they want and then step
into the jaguar shoes where there's no
guarantee you're going to keep him
around beyond this season and it gets
very expensive in 2021 to franchise tag
him a second time all right alden smith
has been out of the league for so long
that the last time he played
dak prescott was the quarterback at
mississippi state dak wasn't even in the
nfl the last time alden smith had a
raiders helmet on dak smith has gotten
to see alden smith in practice now that
they're both members of the dallas
cowboys here's dak from thursday talking
about his impressions of his new
defensive teammate
he's a man he's a he's a monster
damn sure doesn't look like he hasn't
played in five years doesn't play like
it um energy isn't would never tell you
that i'm very fortunate to have him very
fortunate to have him on my team and not
rushing me um he's going to make all of
us better he's a great player
yeah dak prescott the one quarterback
who will never have to worry about aldon
smith this year and
alden smith
his first three years in the nfl he
played in 43 regular season games and
had 42 sacks so what's more likely he
leads the cowboys and sacks this year or
he plays fewer than four games
whoo that's a tough one uh
i'd say plays fewer than four games
although i think he's going to play more
than four games but that's a tough one
to pick i just don't think he's going to
lead the team in sax i mean
he hasn't played a full season since
2012 which leads me toward the fewer
than four games thing
but he hasn't played at all since 2015
and that position did leave the cowboys
as sacks last season that was robert
quinn who departed but they've also
signed everson griffin who's also going
to play that position opposite demarcus
lawrence and lawrence had a down year
last year with five sacks so i'm going
to say demarcus lawrence is going to
lead the team in sacks which leads me to
go with the four games for aldon smith
yeah this is one of those what's more
likely choices where the middle is huge
and i hate to say fewer than four games
for a guy who's been fighting and
scratching and clawing to get back in
the nfl but it is more likely that he
plays fewer than four games than leads
the team in sacks because of the other
guys on the team everything griffin by
the way said yesterday he was named
after everson walls he was a cowboys fan
growing up shireen so he's with the team
now that he always wanted to play for
after 10 years in minnesota all right
dez bryant used to play for the cowboys
what's more likely he scores a touchdown
in 2020 or antonio brown scores a
touchdown in 2020 and we have dez in
there because he had a workout yesterday
with the ravens left without a contract
who's more likely to score a touchdown
this year
well i'm going to go with a b because i
do think a b will be back in the league
after he serves his eight-game
suspension we know that could be longer
given what the commissioner has said but
i think ab gets back in the league he's
in in his prime i think he's gonna score
some touchdowns this season dez stills
question well he left baltimore without
a contract if you go back to 2018 when
he visited the ravens they offered him a
deal and he didn't think it was enough
and he turned that down and he didn't
get anything else close to that until
november he decides to sign with the
saints and what happens he blows out
that achilles right away and and hasn't
played in the in the league since so he
probably should have signed with the
ravens then i don't think he gets an
opportunity again in the nfl
yeah you know i agree with you i i'm not
sure why the ravens brought him in for a
workout part of me wonders is it some
way to placate the guys internally who
have been clamoring for antonio brown i
don't know but uh if he left without a
contract it either means
that the ravens just decided not to make
an offer or dez turned down whatever
they did offer either way
it's been a long time since he's played
and i agree with you i think between the
two there's a greater chance antonio
brown will be back in the nfl before dez
bryant so i agree with you on that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports